the Ops Engineers are one of the highest
paid Professionals in the tech industry
today and if you are watching this video
most likely you are someone who wants to
get into devops or want to learn devops
but with so many different tools and
Technologies like data form and 7 Linux
AWS Jenkins Docker kubernetes and so
much more learning devocs can be very
time consuming and confusing and that is
why in this video I am going to share
with you a complete devops roadmap that
you can follow to learn devops from
scratch and also an excellent resource
you can use to learn all the devops
tools at one place so watch this video
till the end
before we start with the video and look
into the devops roadmap let me introduce
myself my name is nasiulla Chaudhary
also goes by Cloud champ on YouTube and
I work as a freelance devops engineer
for multiple companies the roadmap
shared in this video is the exact
roadmap I followed to learn devops from
scratch and I'm pretty sure if you watch
this video till the end you will have a
clear idea on what things to learn and
what not to learn and get jobs faster
a devops engineer is responsible for
deploying application and automating the
manual process but how can you automate
the manual process if you don't know how
is an application created so first thing
you need to know is to understand the
concepts of software development what is
the build what is software deployment so
generally try to understand the whole
software developer life cycle come idea
to code and to releasing the application
to end users after you understand the
software developer lifecycle and now you
have an idea of how is an application
created second thing you need to know is
Linux Linux is very very important at
the Ops engineer should have a good
Hands-On knowledge with Linux need to
know all the important commands because
every devops tools you look at let's say
ansible terraform kubernetes talker all
of them work on commands and you can
only manage to work with them when you
have good helps or knowledge with Linux
so learn Linux in Linux you can learn
things like shell commands latest file
systems and permissions SSH Key
Management virtualization some part of
networking like load balances how to set
up firewalls how IP addresses work and
much more Linux is very important so
it's also called as operating system of
the cloud so spend time learning Linux
now most of you might be confused and
you might ask let's say I want to know
all these tools but where should I find
the resources you can learn this from
YouTube some of these from blogs some
from documentation but they are all
scattered which will waste your time so
rather than that I would suggest you
checking out an excellent devops program
I simply learn this postgraduate devops
program by simply um is in collaboration
with IBM which will teach you all the
important devops tools that you require
in order to become a devops engineer
like terraform moving ansible Jenkins
Docker kubernetes kit and a lot more
along with industry projects that will
provide you hands-on experience and can
help you become the Ops engineer faster
and also a certification by Caltech
which will validate your learning in
devops so you can check out the learning
path here and reviews by previous
learner why all of them are five star
reviews so click on the link in the
description and click on apply now for
this program you don't acquire any prior
work experience you require a bachelor
degree with an average of 50 or higher
marks you can be from programming or
non-programming background which makes
this program for everyone so click on
the link in the description click on
apply now filling all your details and
proceed to start learning devops with
simply learn
next important thing after learning
Linux is going to be get because every
company is going to store their code
online on git repositories like GitHub
gitlab or bitbucket so what devops
Engineers need to know how to work with
Git to clone and push the code from
local machine to git repositories or
from git repositories to local machine
also understand what is branching how
does branching Works what is merge
request what is pull request and a lot
more so adops engineer should have a
good understanding of git and also know
all the most used git commands
once you have cleared your Basics now is
that I opened in Cloud because devops
Engineers need to know how to create
servers databases storage virtual apcs
and lot more on the cloud you can choose
any cloud like AWS Azure gcp IBM Oracle
or anything but other Ops Engineers need
to know how to create infrastructure to
deploy their applications and software
on the cloud once you have learned how
to create infrastructure and deployer
applications on the cloud manually you
need to automate this because teox is
all about automation so you can automate
this using infrastructure as code tools
like terraform ansible Chef puppet and a
lot more but I would suggest you learn
only these two tools which are terraform
and ansible that are highly used in the
industry today learning ansible and
terraform can provide you with so many
job opportunities so start with learning
terraform and ansible after you have
mastered creating an application on the
cloud manually
due to rise in demand and application
stability companies are shifting from
servers to Containers which is why you
need to learn Docker and kubernetes for
Docker you need to understand the
concepts of virtualization and concept
of containerization also you need to
know how to continuous application
Android on a server or a kubernetes
cluster you need to know the commands on
how to create Docker file how to create
Docker image how to run containers
called networking in Docker and some of
the parts for kubernetes you need to
understand the kubernetes architecture
what its deployment what is replica set
what is POD what is node and how to
properly manage a containerized
application using kubernetes cluster
either on eks AKs or gke which is going
cooperate this engine so it is very
important for you to understand and know
the commands to properly work through
containerization which is a leading and
a popular tool right now in the market
next very important thing for a devops
engineer to learn is going to be CI CD
or continuous integration and continuous
deployment because if every company once
you deploy their application
automatically in devops all code changes
like new features or bug fixes should be
integrated in the existing application
and provided to the end user in an
automated fashion and you can only do
this by using CI CD so adoption you
should know how to set up cicd server
how to integrate code repositories to
trigger pipeline automatically when
there is a change and to fix bug faster
and to provide better quality software
to the end user very fast in automated
fashion some popular cacd tool includes
Jenkins gitlab Circle CI Travis CI so
learning cicd will help you land your
job very very fast and it's very
important also known as heart of devops
so you should master cicd
all the tools that we have mentioned in
now will help you deploy an application
on the cloud or on containers anywhere
but once the software or your
application is in production it is very
important for you to monitor it to track
performance to see if there are any
issues check system resources like CPU
or Ram or anything so one of the
responsibilities of devops engineer is
to set up software monitoring
infrastructure monitoring collect logs
and to visualize data to check if there
are any issues or if system has Nest
resources or not so you need to learn
tools like Prometheus grafana also
logging tools like cloudwatch or elk
stack which is very important to make
sure that your application is running
without any issues and without any
problems congratulations now you know
all the tools and Technologies you
require to become a devops engineer but
devops is all about Automation and there
is always going to be something that you
can automate so to automate this you
will require scripting language and some
of few might argue that scripting is not
required or you don't need any
programming language and devops coding
is not a thing in devops but that's not
actually true you will require knowledge
of one programming language or a
scripting language because you need to
automate the manual process so some
popular scripting language can be bash
Powershell uh which are all OS related
so you can use batch in Linux in
Powershell in Windows and non-os related
our python go Ruby which is what I would
suggest I would suggest you trying to
Learn Python which will help you
automate all the manual process like
rotating passwords of your database is
like starting your deployment starting
your build or appearing cache anything
that you are doing manually can be
automated through scripting languages
using this python or Google or bash my
solution would be to start with python
and if you love python you will be
unstoppable and you will have more value
as a devops engineer and you don't need
to learn any programming language at a
software engineer level you just need to
know enough python or enough go just to
write scripts which can automate your
things you don't need to go deep in DSA
and all those things which are very
common questions that I get so just
focused on learning python in a way
where you can automate things by writing
scripts so just the basics not too
advanced only to automate stuff so there
you have it a complete devops roadmap to
learn things from scratch along with
this make sure you have your LinkedIn
perfect you attend meetups and also
enroll to the simply learned devops
program thank you and have a good day